[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
recevoir tous nos petits amis
j'espère que vous avez passé une belle
journée
avez-vous bien fait votre toilette ce
soir oui mais c'est très bien ça il faut
la faire tous les jours car moi je
connais trois jeunes ne sont pas garants
si vous voulez parler de rémi toto et
fanfan
ils sont très bons
oui bien sûr le doute je crois bien que
pape rhône elle leur a fait prendre un
gros bang ce soir bravo david voir sa
pop bon loll propos
[Musique]
ça sent bon le parfum
bonsoir la maisonnée voilà trois mâts on
peut entrer en trente ans de vie on
était bien à pg on était couvert de plus
jouer mais maintenant ils sont mignons
au début
tiens fin encore été notre collègue glmc
lui laquelle elle n'a pas l'air mal du
tout cette eau de cologne nous un petit
peu seul bon du tout petit
peut-être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hachez toi là on ne criera toilettes
n'est ce pas dire oui la toilette de
notre gros nounours un peu dans les
puces d'abord et voilà lancés plus tôt
[Musique]
bref tout autant où les bains
bouillonnants non je ne fais pas rêver
pour savoir pour être bon et maintenant
aux plats abc les petits allez un petit
peu de savon ainsi rémi jeu ce fut merci
des hauts-fonds où le mot une autre
grenade pour terminer et on fera du bien
comme ça que de bon
c'est vrai je me sens très chaud oui on
a oublié pas c'est vrai un petit peu
seul beau jeu le sait les enfants merci
il faut que j'aille vite montré à mon
patron combien les propres chez nicolas
et pimprenelle comme sow au revoir les
enfants à ma famille on va se coucher
alors les bébés au lit gamigo au fait
plaisir un peu de tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi si la fin de la journée c'est le
moment de ce congé longe faits sont
comme nos amis il sans mon trousseau
lee non et allonge aussi
si on s'ennuie
j'en suis certain le marchand de sable
vienne
il nous dira fermez vos yeux et dormi
tous les deux nous sommes bien dans
notre lit nos noces ou souhaitent avoir
une nuit sa grosse voix au fait plaisir
quand je vais m'endormir je vais
m'endormir
safra nous fait plaisir
[Musique]
le
ou pour beaucoup j'entends nounours qui
remonte en chantant pour c'est signe que
tout va pour le mieux pour au port on
voit la patron je suis bonne
bon c'est vrai nounours et tu respires
la propreté toujours pas trop toujous
allons en route modèle de vertu bonne
nuit de l'enfant
de bourrel à demain à deux pas bowles
[Musique]
oh